when I mentioned to people that I'd be
making a new series focused on real-life
legends almost everyone responded by
saying you're gonna make one on our knee
right that's partly because everyone
knows how much I love our knee but it's
also because irony is the absolute
epitome of the expression living legend
you might know him as the highly
successful bodybuilder turned movie star
turned governor but there's more to his
story than that and much more we can
learn from the man so let's take a
closer look at what makes our knee such
a legend and what we can learn from him
in terms of business self-promotion
strength training and goal-setting
Annie was born Arnold alloy shruts and
they get to his parents Gustav and
aralia Schwarzenegger in 1947 he grew up
in his hometown of tie in Styria
Austria Arnold was close to his mother
and Gustav reportedly demonstrated a
clear preference for Arnold's older
brother mine hard at school Arnold was
described as academically average
getting by on his cheerful and good
human manner and exuberant character and
this is one of the first things that we
can learn from Arnie at this young age
he's a shrewd businessman yes he's a
fantastic bodybuilder but what people
often don't focus on is that he's also
just a really fun and charismatic guy
and this can carry you've an awfully
long way in pretty much any field
remember we do everything in reps so
you've done two reps of water drinking
usually we do 10 reps of everything so
do another rep of water drinking lots of
people we've worked with him talk about
how he made it fun how he made it
memorable and enjoyable and that will
help to gravitate people towards you
help to make you more influential so
whatever it is you're doing try and make
it fun try and make it enjoyable and be
positive and optimistic along the way
Arnold was inspired at the age of 14 to
begin weightlifting by screen icons reg
Park and Steve Reeves just as he's gone
on to inspire many others himself it was
then that his master plan to travel to
the US on the back of a bodybuilding
career began to form he was incredibly
driven and dedicated even breaking into
his local gym so he could train when it
was closed at weekends similarly when
serving his conscripted time in the
Austrian army Arne went AWOL during
basic training in order to attend the
mr. Europe competition which he won
Arnie said of the experience
participating in the competition meant
so much to me but I didn't carefully
think through the consequences and this
of course is one of the other really
important lessons from Arnie diehard
single-minded determination
Arnie someone who was so set on working
towards a goal nothing was going to
stand between him and a workout it's
important that we have that same kind of
drive but rather than trying to force
yourself to be passionate and driven
about something that you're not
particularly interested in the key is to
find a goal find a passion that really
does make you enthusiastic so that you
can't wait to get out of bed in the
morning it shouldn't be a chore if you
really love what you're doing and if you
have fun with it along the
Arnold of course went on to place in
several more big bodybuilding
competitions being named the best built
a man in Europe off the back of this
success he travelled to London to attend
the naba mr. universe competition where
he placed second - Chester your turn
this though gave him the opportunity to
stay in the city with his new mentor and
coach Charles wag Bennett and during
this time he also got to train with this
childhood hero reg Park training with
the icon Schwarzenegger eventually won
mr. universe in 1967 at the age of 20
and he's gone on to win the title three
more times between 1966 and 1968 army
attempted business school in Munich
while working at Rolfe put Seger's gym
he also got English coaching during this
time telling his coach regularly that he
was going to become the greatest actor
really shouldn't understate the extent
of Arnie's vision here despite being
focused at the time on his bodybuilding
career he had the foresight to develop
himself in business in speech and these
are things that of course helped him an
awfully long way through every stage of
his career talks about this in my video
on digital polymaths how you can keep on
training keep on learning and that way
expand your CV your skill set and become
more of a jack-of-all-trades Arnie was
definitely a polymath and he was always
learning always adding new skills in
order to keep transitioning from one
phase of his career to the next in 1968
at the age of 21
Arnie finally realized his dream of
moving to the United States there he
would train under Joe Weider at Gold's
Gym receiving a $65 a week's tip end and
frequently appearing on the cover of the
media moguls magazines Arnie was a sure
draw for selling magazines owned as much
to his persona and charisma as his
incredible physique he also wrote two
regular columns for the magazines and he
went on to win his first mr. Olympia
title the most prestigious of
bodybuilding awards in 1970 and he'd win
that seven more times to this day he's
still the youngest ever winner during
this time
Arnie also gained a bachelor's degree in
international business marketing of
fitness and Business Administration from
the University of wisconsin-superior he
also penned his first book in 1977
education of a bodybuilder what many
people don't realize is that Arnie was
already a millionaire at this point I
mean his best friend Franco
booooo-whoo he'd met in Germany labeled
themselves as specialty European
bricklayers turning their accents and
immigrant status into an asset of course
they're gigantic muscles also likely
helped to set them apart from the
competition
Annie also set up a mail-order business
selling booklets and leaflets to fancy
wrote in with bodybuilding questions
Annie said of the enterprise many
bodybuilders failed at mail-order
because they'd accept the money but not
getting together to mail the product he
had to fill the orders within a certain
time by law and if the post office
received complaints it would take away
your post-office box and your business
would be gone but I was super efficient
there are bins for incoming mail checks
envelopes and outgoing orders I always
showed Joe Joe Weider his mentor any ad
I wrote before putting it in the
magazine because he was a merchandising
genius why don't you write fill within
days he'd ask put that in the ad people
want to know you're dependable and he
should say this book is a limited
edition
people love limited edition you see time
and time again through our earnest
career how his ability to market himself
was really one of his key skills what
made him stand out in terms of
bricklaying bodybuilding acting politics
he managed to find a way to
differentiate himself and make himself
more memorable and more exciting than
the competition being able to market
yourself is something that you should
definitely spend time learning and
developing because it will help you in
relationships and business in every area
of your life and the secret is often not
to focus on the logic but rather to
focus on the emotion the value
proposition what is it about what you're
offering that's exciting and different
from everyone else and the other lessons
to take from this is efficiency and also
sticking to your word if you develop a
reputation for being flaky in business
relationships any other aspects of your
life then you won't be successful
Arnie made sure that when someone bought
his courses they got them which might
sound simple but you'd be surprised how
many of these smaller businesses fail on
that very fundamental test you must
never think about a job as being
unimportant or beneath you even if
you're a checkout assistant and you hate
your job and you're just doing it as a
summer stopgap you should be efficient
you should be helpful you could be
friendly this will help you to succeed
you never know who's listening you never
know who's watching and you never know
what opportunities could arise from that
if you put in the time and the work I
found myself in my writing business that
what's really set me apart is just
making sure that I deliver my work on
time every time even if that sometimes
means I have to work till 3:00 a.m. to
get it all finished all of Arnie's money
would be reinvested into real estate
starting with the purchase of a six Plex
apartment building he lived in apartment
number six and mented out the other five
he'd go on to make money and many more
savvy investments to even being the
first private individual to invest in a
passenger plane which he eventually sold
for eleven million dollars in 1998 so
during this time
Annie was completing a degree running
multiple businesses and thriving as a
bodybuilding world champion to keep
himself together he recently reported
that he would use Transcendental
Meditation to avoid letting all of his
challenges become one big problem
something else many people don't realize
about Arnie is that he also competed in
powerlifting and weightlifting
competitions and enjoyed several
victories in those fields too in 1967
for instance he won the Munich stone
lifting competition by lifting a two
hundred and fifty-four kilogram stone he
was not just massive he was genuinely
strong with his personal bests on squat
two bench press and deadlift being 247
kilograms 240 kilograms and 320
kilograms respectively Arnie retired
from bodybuilding in 1975 but he returns
once more to compete and become mr.
Olympia again in a slightly
controversial decision in 1980 he is
famous for using psychological warfare
prior to competition in order to
unsettle his opponents it's worth
reading education of a bodybuilder if
you want to understand more about
Arnie's training at this time whilst
some advice is dated other sections are
still highly useful and provide some
lesser-known
tips Annie for instance says that he
prefers training outdoors where possible
to help fuel the body with oxygen he
also talks about the importance of a
relaxed and carefree attitude
Arnold also talks about the importance
of an enthusiastic training partner and
of course that would be Franco in his
case the two would regularly trained
together at Gold's Gym and Muscle Beach
despite technically competing for the
same title Ernie is still best friends
with Franco Columbu to this day and
continues to train and to support the
bodybuilding industry as well as his
hometown in Austria
despite accomplishing so much he
demonstrates a remarkable loyalty in
areas
of his life he's also formed a close
friendship with one-time rival Sylvester
Stallone I personally believe that these
close relationships helped to give him
the positivity that has been so
prevalent throughout his career of
course not all of Arnold's relationships
have been so ideal but no one's perfect
I guess so in the gym Annie would bring
his same trademark focus and
determination and really concentrate on
the muscle he was training he espouses
the importance of the mind muscle
connection if your mind is elsewhere for
answering texts then you're not getting
a hundred percent out of your workouts
he would use largely rep ranges of
around eight to ten and he'd use a lot
of Joe Weider's intensity techniques
things like drop sets cheats forced reps
in order to really pull the blood and
the muscles build up those metabolites
and get the pump that was ultimately
result in hypertrophy with rest and
relaxation of course the rest of our mo
story is better known and from this
success in bodybuilding he went on to
launch a highly successful acting career
eventually becoming the highest-paid
actor in Hollywood under the pseudonym
Arnold strong he played the role of
Hercules in 1969 Hercules in New York he
had several other bit parts following
that but perhaps his first big
breakthrough was in the documentary film
pumping iron opposite Hulk actor Lou
Ferrigno Arnie made sure to capitalize
on the exposure here by playing an
exaggerated version of his own character
chewing scenery and making multiple bold
and controversial statements becoming an
instant standout he went on to star in
Conan the Barbarian in 1982 which would
be his first a box-office hit following
that was terminator from little-known
director James Cameron which of course
was also quite successful during this
time Arnie demonstrated a remarkable
radar for picking out the best script
the ones that were to turn into
blockbuster hits but he was also very
good at choosing films that would play
to his strengths he turned things like
his thick accent and his large physique
into assets was otherwise they might
have been detrimental to his success
later on he would go on to demonstrate
exceptional adaptability to
transitioning from violent action films
to family-friendly comedic roles that
utilize his comic timing and charisma
this helped him to become a true
household name and no doubt laid the
foundation for his subsequent political
career Ernie became involved in politics
long before rising to prominence as
governor of caliph
or Nia with his first appointment being
chairman of the President's Council on
physical fitness and sports between 1990
and 1993 of course
Arne also married into a political
family when he married to Maria Shriver
in 1986 Arne announced his candidacy for
the 2003 California recall election on
August 6 and 1 despite a large smear
campaign against him CBS News reported
that voters focused much more on the
candidates leadership and personal
qualities once again showing the role of
emotion in decision-making and marketing
of course Arne also put a lot of his
skills and self-promotion and marketing
to use here once again along with his
skillful one-liners and slogans he did
not accept the usual governor's salary
he was reelected in 2006 with a margin
of over 1 million votes he only
demonstrated his ability to use one
success to springboard and launch
himself into his next project you don't
have to take the most obvious a linear
path from bottom of the corporate ladder
to the top often you can take any kind
of route to reach the destination you
want to get to moving horizontally
between industries and using success in
one area to help propel yourself in a
completely different area just as he
would invest his money into properties
so he'd invest each success in order to
give himself more clout in a different
area so think about what skills and
experience you've developed you can may
be applied to a completely different
career or a different area of your life
think about the connections you've built
and the opportunities that you already
have that you might be missing and he
was incredibly shrewd at seizing
opportunities whether Arnold's tenure as
governor was a successful knot is a
point of contention as with any
politician opinions vary drastically on
Army's policies and performance he left
with a low approval rating of 23% but
many say did a reasonable job under the
circumstances inheriting the impact of
the recession in 2008 and going up
against an established state Democratic
Party environmentalism is a cause that's
close to Arnold's heart and one that he
repeatedly champion about his time as
governor signing bills with the aim of
reducing emissions by 25% by 2020
Arne describes himself as a moderate
Republican being fiscally Republican and
socially liberal he takes a pragmatic
approach putting policy before party and
making long-term decisions that weren't
necessarily serve his best interests he
was known to work with Paula
from both parties and he's been
outspoken against many members of his
own party one thing that is certain is
that he was a rare politician since
stepping down as governor Arne has
returned to acting and continues to be
vocally political speaking out against
gerrymandering and various other issues
he engages in a lot of charitable and
philanthropic work perhaps most
entertaining being his will it to crush
series of YouTube videos for
after-school all-stars he is generally
adapted very well to the social media
age to building a large following across
multiple platforms and using them to
promote his various projects and causes
Arnie is set to stone Andy Terminator
film directed once again by James
Cameron and to produce and star in a
series called outrider for Amazon
Studios
I'm immensely curious to see where his
career takes him next again no one's
perfect and that obviously includes arms
for art's mega however he's certainly
incredibly inspirational in terms of
what he's achieved and the way he's
achieved it he's the epitome of the
expression self-made man and this post
hasn't even come close to discussing
everything that he's achieved or every
project he's been involved in but
perhaps the most important take-home
from all this is to have a singular goal
a singular vision that really excites
you and that drives you and then to work
with single-minded determination towards
that and not make any excuses I guess
you want to follow in Arnie's footsteps
and the question you need to ask
yourself is what are you doing right now
to move towards your goals what have you
done today those moves you closer to
your goals and your goals don't need to
be as massive as Arnie's you don't need
to be aiming to be the president or an
action movie star it could just mean
trying to get a better house or it could
just mean enjoying your work whatever it
is identify how you can improve things
and then work towards them and take
concrete steps to actually get there
don't just daydream make the effort I
always find interesting how a lot of
really well-built Hollywood actors like
Jackie Chan or our Schwarzenegger or
Dolph Lundgren or Sylvester Stallone or
of course the way in the rock Johnson
these guys are all not only successful
in Hollywood but they've also been
successful in countless other fields in
other areas that are all polymaths in
one way or another and I think that's
because as Arnie says he learned
everything that he needed to know from
bodybuilding in bodybuilding there are
notes
if you don't train if you don't eat
right if you don't rest then you won't
grow and you won't get stronger likewise
in all those other areas building
businesses or pursuing a dream project
there aren't any excuses you need to put
in the work you need to grind and do the
small things when nobody else is
watching that's what makes you
successful in those areas so many people
talk about how they're going to change
their body so many people talk about how
they're going to launch a new business
or how they're going to travel the world
but they don't actually take any steps
to get there it's all talk and imagine
to achieve all these things while still
having friendships and relationships and
a lot of fun along the way and if you
don't have time to do all that well then
as Arnie says sleep faster
speaking of business and marketing and
promoting yourself you might have
noticed that I'm wearing a bio near
t-shirt this is a new thing a lot of you
guys asked where you could buy
merchandise for the bio near which I'm
very grateful for thanks for that so if
you'd like to get yourself a t-shirt
like this and check out the link in the
description down below or head over to
the bar near comm and I'm sure I'll be
promoting it all over there I'm also
doing tank tops and soon I'll be adding
hoodies and things maybe mugs etc
likewise let me know what you'd like to
see with the bio near logo on it so
thanks ton for watching guys I hope you
found this video useful and interesting
if you did then please consider leaving
a like sharing it around that helps me
out immensely I hope you like this new
series let me know in the comments down
below who else you'd like to see me
cover in future videos I've also got a
lot more of the usual stuff on the way
I'm also gonna be looking at two shinobi
training I'm gonna be looking at
Nightwing training I'm gonna be talking
about cognitive biases how to build a
youtube business so if all that sounds
cool then thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now
you